(Guitar music starts)
I've been looking
Several days now
Where did they go?
My mama told me long ago
I've lost so many precious things, I know
They won't be back
Where did they go?
My mama told me long ago
Ain't nobody's ever gonna tell me
to abandon my old friend
Happy days, walking on the shore
Ain't nobody's ever gonna tell me
to abandon my good memories at all
I've seen so many pretty things
They don't mean a thing now
Listen to the song
My mama told me long ago
Ain't nobody's ever gonna tell me
to doubt my good old days
Happy days, walking on the shore
Ain't nobody's ever gonna tell me
to abandon my good memories at all
Abandon my good memories at all
(Music ends)
(Applause)
Thank you.
Thank you for giving me the opportunity
to perform tonight at TED New York.
I've been a dedicated TED fan and viewer,
and also, I actually used to live
in Manhattan when I was younger,
so New York is like a second home to me,
and it's great to be back.
The song I just performed
was called "my mama,"
and the next song I'm going to perform
is another original song of mine
called "BLACK BANANA."
This song I wrote about the importance
of being patient with your dreams.
Because I think commitment
will always be rewarded.
Just like fruit ripens
when the time is right.
So it's my interpretation
of building the future.
(Guitar music starts)
Clap your hands.
One!
Two!
One, two, one, two, three, four.
Sitting here, killing time,
I've been doing it all day
I've been always smart
when it comes to gettin' away
Got a soda pop fizzin' hard
in my empty brain
When the time is right I'll move
alright so don't get too uptight
Silly girls in bathing suits
cleaning cars on Sundays
They're living a lie
don't make as fool of yourself too soon
Lining my bananas
on the window sill to ripen
When the time is right I'll move
alright so don't get too uptight
Bananananana sekasanaide
Bananananana-ri yuki makase
Bananananana mō ato
chotto dake jukusu made
Black Banana Black Banana
Banananananana
Remember last December
when we went to get some pizza
Was a brat, was running fast
to get home by my curfew
Silly me, tripping quick,
I was almost killed by a honker
When the time is right I'll move
alright so don't get too uptight
Bananananana isoganaide
Bananananana-ri yuki makase
Bananananana mō ato
chotto dake jukusu made
Black Banana Black Banana
Banananananana
Bananananana Don't push me baby
Bananananana All I want is leeway
Bananananana You gotta be patient
for the fruit to ripen
Black Banana Black Banana
Banananana
Bananananana isoganaide
Bananananana-naru yoni nare
Bananananana wagamamana mi ga jukusu made
Black Banana Black Banana
Bananananana
Banananananana
(Music ends)
Thank you.
(Applause)
(Guitar music)
(Music ends)
(Applause)